York is a city steeped in history with
roots as a Roman Fortress before Viking
and Norman occupation
historic streets and buildings tell a
story linking layers of our past to the
present day which is why it's one of
seven UK locations in the running for
UNESCO world heritage status
a mark of cultural significance that
tourists feel is well overdue
are there so many layers historical
layers in New York and they keep the
city alive for a lot of farm visitors as
well be really difficult it's different
to Bath it's different to London and
it's it's got a character in that
history to it that don't find elsewhere
I would say come it's very welcome and
there's something for everybody for Nick
who runs free tours a day here UNESCO
recognition will mean Better Business I
believe that what that will develop is
bringing in more people into the City
and we are quite famous anyway but I
think if we've got unesco's site it
really shows how passionate we are
protecting our heritage and it's
cultural past and its future and
developing its future as a city not just
a tourist City you know generating
businesses that as shown in what York's
got to offer as a whole really becoming
a UNESCO world heritage site will come
with benefits for York or anywhere else
that gets the nod some are obvious like
increased publicity and tourism but the
prestigious status also gives access to
funding for its protection and
conservation
there are half a dozen other sites of
government backing including birkenhead
Park in merseyside the Marine Park of
the Cayman Islands and the Zenith of
Iron Age Shetland
a tour guide from Shetland says its
inclusion is a reminder remote locations
are historically important too we want
different types of people to come to
Chevron to come for different reasons
here's another one to come for them to
come to and in a more remote out of the
way exciting extraordinary place
whether it's York or another of the
country's Treasures one is almost
certain to become Britain's 34th UNESCO
world heritage site the rest will have
to wait a decade for the chance to come
again
Sky News York